The Joe Rogan Experience do you think
that enough people realized
because that's the thing if you're just
hanging out with someone if you're
hanging out with me and eventually I
start lying to you all the time
are you gonna take anything I say
seriously right it's over who in your
life do you know that lies all the time
that you take seriously and you take
seriously no no so now that every Media
Group
that exists
lied right to your face write it like
while they were doing they were someone
had been writing it going oh my God this
is like such dick stuff but I love being
you know what it's like the corporations
we want to think of them as being these
impossibly large machines that make
money and they are but they're just run
by people and some people are dorks and
those dorks get important jobs and they
put Dylan Mulvaney on a Bud Light can
that's what it is these are dorks
and you see the response that bud had
the most recent response it's it's like
the [__] dumbest
pro-america raw rah-rah like we don't
know who you really are now there's like
interviews with the lady who is the the
head of Bud Light talking about why they
did it and about the old sort of frat
culture attached to Bud Light dismissing
the people and like the humor of the
people that like Bud Light and so
they're going to change that with with
this crazy attention [__] on
65 of being a woman I mean
when Coen Brothers movie this is a Mike
Judge movie you're a thousand percent
correct like how does no how does nobody
else see
what what lunacy is going on there's no
other way to explain it bro you got to
watch this Bud Light commercial this new
Bud Light commercial find the news this
is like it's the dumbest pro-america
rah-rah it's so stupid and cliche it
[__] it hurts my feelings it's so
dumb
listen
this is a company in deep [__] bro and
they make things like this look you got
the Prairies the ocean you got a
Clydesdale running down the street story
about a beer
in the heart of America
found in a community
where a handshake is a sure contract
what the [__] are you talking about
opportunity and challenge you know I
would respect what this is if they had
this and then Dylan Mulvaney just starts
cartwheeling Into The Fray
368 of Womanhood this is what some CEOs
like who is who is in charge ah he's 90
years old get him come on this is how we
used to do it he's the goddamn
Clydesdale first of all
this is the story of the American Spirit
shut the [__] up wow shut the [__] up
now I hate you more
like what are you doing what is that
what was that you can't you can't come
out in in like chicks clothes and then
turn around and bring a stallion out
well the problem is what I saw if you
let CEOs talk about stuff like that and
give their opinions about stuff like
that then everybody knows who you are so
you can't just make this commercial like
where's this coming from was this AI
generated that's probably a chat GPT 4.0
version of the perfect American
Commercial that's really what it is that
that [__] didn't have nothing to do with
drinking Bud Light either by the way
that was like that made me want to move
to Montana like you want to be in the
mountains and see the dust and [__] but
that that's like the dummies commercial
of all time but it's so obvious what
they're doing they're trying to like
they needed to let that sit for a little
bit but that's what I'm saying you don't
have one or two guys on the board going
I don't know if this is a good decision
bro I don't I don't think they get to I
think that lady made a decision
and she thought inclusiveness is
important and we're gonna open up the
brand to new people or it's like is this
like an organized crime hit the thing is
like if she didn't make the the thing
about frat boy culture if she didn't
like kind of disparage what was her
exact quote see if you could find her
exact quote she didn't disparage the the
the humor of the people that enjoy the
product like that is such a crazy move
well that's what I'm saying is this like
an organ in my head I go wacky but what
I'm saying is like if she's just said
like everyone can like Bud Light like if
that was her and she's like America is
the freedom to be whoever the [__] you
want to be what did you see if that's
what they said I'd be like okay great
she she was um disparaging she was
talking about inclusivity and talking
about like the sort of frat culture
around Bud Light CEO's name is Brendan
Whitworth
is that the guy I don't know there was a
woman saying yes that's that's a man so
that this person was a woman unless I'm
misgendering them Jesus Christ don't say
it
um uh it was a woman for sure there's
videos of her talking about it there's
videos of her um talking about why she
made the decision to do this
but it's like you can say that we want
other people like America's freedom and
you the freedom to be whoever you want
if you want to be a woman for day 368
that's your freedom too but if you're
doing that and trying to like change who
buys the company and dismiss all the
other people by the company buy the the
beer from the company that's so dumb
it's like such a silly move well that's
some it's so weird to me I instantly
always see mob hits yeah
I see a mob hit just walking in like
your company's done what do you mean
[__] done what do you mean
everyone's [__] out put on the uh
thing that's gonna get rid of their
crowd you don't think you're [__]
you'll never kill us oh really let's run
into town Oh you mean like someone did
it to try to kill Bud Light dude they're
[__] what a great hit
that would be amazing if Heineken snuck
in and did that to them say hi someone
came in there